il nous revient aujourd'hui l'honneur
vous présenter le bilan des mesures qui
ont été mises en oeuvre par mon
ministère
suite au grenelle des violences
conjugales
je veux d'abord le fer avec humilité
puisque ces dernières semaines ont été
marquées par la mort de plusieurs femmes
qui sont tombés sous les coups de leur
conjoint mais je veux aussi faire avec
conviction parce que ce sont des efforts
sans précédent qui ont été réalisés par
les juridictions et par les services du
ministère je vous dis en un mot ma
détermination comme la vôtre d'ailleurs
et et sans faille pour lutter contre ces
violences qui sont eux absolument
indigne de notre civilisation
[Musique]
alors vous m'interrogez sur le pour
m'interroger sur le bilan chiffré est
extrêmement et barbe hâtif les chiffres
mais c'est plus explicite au moment du
bidon que que les mots dont je vais vous
livrer les chiffres d'abord sur le
budget de l'aide aux victimes de
violences intrafamiliales
j'évoque évidemment 2021 sûr et je vous
précise que depuis cinq ans l'ensemble
du budget de l'aide aux victimes
augmentée de 25% mais crédit
spécifiquement dédié aux associations et
aux dispositifs d'aidé aux victimes de
violences conjugales représentant un
budget de 18 millions d'euros en 2021
4,5 millions d'euros pour les
subventions directes aux associations
des deux victimes
13,5 millions pour les dispositifs
spécifiquement dédiée à la protection
des victimes
je voudrais dire que maintenant pour le
g prochain qui est en cours de
discussion j'entends continuer
évidemment cet effort au 5 juillet 2021
mais nommée sénatrice bestiaux les
sénateurs ses 234 bracelet anti
rapprochement qui ont été prononcées 160
300 sont actifs
vous en aviez prévu le déploiement par
la loi du 28 décembre 2019 je me suis
engagé ce que mille dispositif soit
disponible en septembre 2020 l'objectif
a été tenu quatre mois l'ensemble des
juridictions a été doté de cet
équipement de cet équipement pardon ya
aucun plafond d'emplois et à chaque fois
qu'un bras c est attribué un autre est
commandée par le spip pour que les
juridictions est un stock constants on a
pu constater on y reviendra bien sûr
vous l'avez évoqué le fait que ces
bracelets ne soit pas assez distribués
et j'ai dit d'ailleurs avec force
v manche qu'il n'avait pas vocation à
rester dans les tiroirs
personne ne pourra nous faire le grief
de ne pas en avoir livré suffisamment
revanche on peut penser que ils n'ont
pas été attribués comme ils auraient dû
l'être mais
nous en parlerons je rappelle également
que la victime a son mot à dire sur
l'attribution du bracelet que parfois ce
que les associations oublie de rappeler
les victimes ne souhaitent pas à leur
conjoint soit porteur d'un tel
dispositif une réflexion qu'il
conviendra de mener pour savoir si on
outre pas sa volonté de la victime pour
être peut-être plus efficace mais plus
intrusif alors question que je pose sans
y répondre à cet instant par deux
dépêches qui ont été signalés 19 et 27
mai 2021 qui ont été qualifiés de
comminatoire par certains magistrats du
parquet j'ai attiré l'attention des
juridictions sur ce dispositif en
demandant qu'un référent soit nommé dans
chaque cour d'appel et dans chaque
tribunal judiciaire et en quelques
semaines on a assisté à une véritable
accélération du prononcé du bracelet
anti rapprochement depuis le début du
déploiement de la mesure on dénombre 146
demandes d'intervention des forces de
sécurité intérieure suite au
déclenchement d'une alarme se sont
évidemment autant de créer un book
l'éviter et je le dis parce que c'est
important
autant de crimes éviter qu'ils ne feront
jamais la une des journaux car il n'a
échappé à personne ici que l'on
développe parfois des fins politiciennes
d'ailleurs une vision fait diversier de
la justice
la justice ce n'est pas que les crimes
qui sont commis une injustice à une
obligation désormais qui est
naturellement de punir les criminels
mais c'était une obligation unique il ya
de cela quelques années mais aussi de le
comptabiliser d'intervenir en amont ce
qui est beaucoup plus compliqué parce
que même équipé d'un bracelet anti
rapprochement vous n'empêcherez jamais
un fou furieux d'aller à les tuer sa
femme et il faut rappeler ces choses
autre outil de protection extrêmement
efficace bien sûr c'est le téléphone
grave danger
nous comptabilisons 2 ans + 434% de
téléphone graves dangers qui ont été
attribués aux victimes au 30 juin 2021
c'est 2048 téléphone grand danger s'ils
ont été déployés dont 75% sont attribués
à des victimes soient 1529 les 25%
restants sont dans les juridictions pour
faire face aux urgences ion le premier
ministre vient d'annoncer d'ailleurs eu
une augmentation de cdd et nous allons
atteindre le chiffre de 3000 1 d'ores et
déjà la commande est passée en 2020 pour
venir l'efficacité de cet outil c'est
1185 déclenchement des forces de
sécurité intérieure suite à une alerte à
une alerte victimes
et là encore c'est autant de crimes ou
de violences hésiter qui ne font là bien
sûr pas la une des journaux ce que l'on
souligne c'est les récits pas celles qui
sont évités c'est pas les crimes qui ne
sont pas commis ou les violences qui ne
sont pas commises
évoquant les violences pour julian a
aussi mis l'accent sur l'utilisation
insuffisante de l' ordonnance de
protection
on vous l'avait rappelé la présidente la
loi de décembre 2019 à faciliter l'accès
cette procédure est encadré sont
prononcés dans le délai de 6 jours le
bars et maintenant également partie des
mesures qui peuvent être décidées par le
juge aux affaires familiales
s'il demandait et est accepté et là
aussi j'ai vu un certain nombre de
choses qui sont dites qu'ils sont
colportées parfois même par des
associations et qui ne sont pas le fruit
de la réalité car en matière civile
il faut évidemment le consentement ce
qui n'est pas le cas en matière pénale
pour promouvoir cette mesure
un comité national de l' ordonnance de
protection dont la présidence a été
confiée
ernestine ronai responsable de
l'observatoire des violences faites aux
femmes de la seine saint denis a été
instituée il vient de remettre son
rapport d'activité jeu tient évidemment
à votre entière disposition
et les résultats sont au rendez vous les
chiffres démontrent une appropriation
par tous du dispositif avec 66,4 % de
demandes entre 2018 et 2020 +76 virieu
5% de décisions pondu le taux
d'acceptation est passé de 61 nuls puis
% à 66 7 % en 2020 de 4900 de décisions
ont été rendues donc 3205 en acceptant
la demande la protection des victimes de
violences conjugales passe aussi bien
sûr par la protection des enfants qui
sont exposés qui subissent ainsi un
traumatisme majeur
si vous souhaitez nous nous pourrons
évoquer ce sujet dans le cadre de nos
échanges et je voudrais vous livrer à
cet instant une réflexion qui est qui
est la mienne je vous en parlerai
naturellement avec tous ceux qui
souhaitent en parle avec moi avec mes
services bien sûr les enfants ne sont
nantes accès au statut de victime que
quand un crime est commis quand des
violences sont commises ils n'ont pas
accès à ce stade une victime il ya peut
être là matière à réflexion et l'enfant
qui voire même s'il n'est pas lui-même
victime de violence des violences
exercées sur sa mère il est pour moi
intrinsèquement une victime
faut-il judiciariser faut-il permettre
d'accéder à la justice sa l'institution
judiciaire
c'est une c'est une question que je me
pose c'est une réflexion que que je
souhaite mener vous mentionner également
mme la présidente
les bonnes pratiques alors dès mon
arrivée à la chancellerie
j'ai fait un constat assez singulier
profond
chaque procureur dans son ressort met en
place non pas une politique pénale c'est
le gouvernement qui décide de la
politique pénale et la chancellerie en
particulier mais des pratiques qui ne
sont pas forcément étendue et c'est
désespérant parce que il ya de très
bonnes pratiques qui restent confinés
dans les limites territoriales du
ressort donc le justiciable de cet
endroit bénéficiera de bonnes pratiques
alors que le justiciable qui habite 10
kilomètres plus loin mais qu'il est plus
en même temps ne bénéficiera pas j'aurai
vous donner quelques exemples de bonnes
pratiques jeu mais pardon je sors un peu
du champ qui est du périmètre qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui mais à bordeaux par
exemple on a mis en place une convention
qui permet de distribuer les scellés aux
associations caritatives
c'est formidable je suis allé à bordeaux
on a inauguré cela il y avait des draps
des baskets neuves évidemment qu'ils
avaient été saisis qui avait pour
vocation de finir sous là sous la
poussière et dans l'obscurité d'une
salle
du tribunal judiciaire
ces objets ont été sortis ils ont été
distribués cette bonne pratique la gym
et pourquoi ça se fait pas par tous
parce que les salles de sceller regorge
d'objets on a envisagé un moment de
contact et les justiciables par le
téléphone
ça c'est la copine qui nous a amené
cette pratique formidable pratique si
j'en ai les gens qui consultent
davantage leur téléphone que leur boîte
aux lettres quand il on monte une et
donc comment on pouvait distribuer ces
bonnes pratiques je vous parle un
instant de méthodologie soit je prenais
une circulaire par bonnes pratiques
elle aurait fini par caler le pied d'un
immeuble bancal personne ne les aurait
lu soir et j'ai fait ça avec une de mes
conseillère qui est appelé la
conseillère bonnes pratiques titre nous
aussi on est une titre de noblesse qui a
répertorié toutes les bonnes pratiques
elle même qui a fait remonter les bonnes
pratiques et nous les avons remis sur un
site qui est une espèce de google à
l'intention des magistrats de la pjj de
l'administration pénitentiaire de tous
les personnels de du ministère et donc
il y à cette possibilité non seulement
d'aller
sur les bonnes pratiques en cliquant
mais également de de proposer de
nouvelles pratiques et le 18 mars j'ai
lancé donc ce moteur de recherche sur
internet pour que on s'approprie ces
choses qui marchent bien et aujourd'hui
c'est 170 ch qui les recense en ligne
avec les outils les témoignages
permettant à chacun de s'en saisir et
concernant les luttes la lutte les lutte
contre les violences conjugales
ces 25 dispositif qui ont été partagés
mais je le dis avec beaucoup de fierté
c'est un si vous permettez cette
familiarité mais vous allez me
l'autorisé c'est un carton parce que
tout le monde y va et dans des domaines
sont totalement différentes toutes les
juridictions partage ce qui marche bien
on sent particulier aux mesures
d'hébergement de la mesure d'hébergement
c'est fondamental on sait qu'il ya une
montée en puissance de la violence quand
le conjoint qui a été écarté au fond
veut revenir dans ce qu'il considère
être chez lui et on lui monsieur c'est
pas possible
et c est là il ya un vrai risque donc
l'hébergement est aussi en prendre à
prendre évidemment en considération a
bordeaux ils ont fait des choses
fantastiques
c'est sur le site et tous les magistrats
up évidemment partagé ce site c'est sa
vocation et au delà du partage des
bonnes pratiques on travaille également
sur sur des expérimentations
l'une d'elles s'est suivi d'aidé
conjoint violent connaît des résultats
très très positifs dont je pourrais
évidemment vous parler on va aller
parler madame madame la présidente d'un
parquet spécialisé dans les violences
conjugales comme c'est le cas en matière
de terrorisme
à l'issue du grenelle le choix n'a pas
été celui
de faire des tribunaux spécialisés tels
qu'il en existe en espagne
tous les tribunaux du territoire ne
pouvant accueillir en raison de leur
taille d'abord une telle juridiction une
inégalité traitement en résulterait
inévitablement je crois mais ça ça ne
regarde que moi que la matière
terroriste est une mesure tout à fait
particulière avec des spécificités qui
nécessite effectivement une juridiction
spécialisée
je pense que tous les magistrats sont en
mesure de traiter des violences faites
aux femmes dans la dans la technicité
dans l'appréhension des textes et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs il y a depuis
longtemps une habitude
hélas de ce type de ce type de
contentieux la direction des services
judiciaires a établi dans le dans un
guide le parcours idéal du traitement
judiciaire d'un dossier de violences
conjugales et aujourd'hui on peut
considérer au 31 décembre 2020 72e
édition ont mis en place ou sont en
train de mettre en place les filières de
l'urgence
le 27 mai dernier par une dépêche
d'inviter toutes les juridictions à
poursuivre dans cette voie et instituts
et les comités de pilotage violences
intrafamiliales mettant autour d'une
même table tous les acteurs judiciaires
de la lutte contre les violences
conjugales
ils répondent à la nécessité
décloisonner les services de coordonner
une dispositifs tels qu'ils ont été
rappelés par les dernières inspections
cesser les affaires dramatiques que vous
évoquez madame la présidente
on peut évidemment pas réécrire
l'histoire mais on peut quand même se
dire que si les services s'étaient
concertés s'il avait été changée
d'avantagé ans inconsciente les services
en seul mon périmètre comme ceux hors de
mon périmètre ce qui à la police et a
laissé pipe il ya le japon il ya le
procureur et ils ne se sont pas parlés
c'est une évidence chaque instant
dans les limites de ce qu'il pense être
son action efficace et donc ça c'est une
véritable difficulté et j'ai incité de
sas en clair comminatoire m'a-t-on dit
mais peu m'importe j'assume sans ça fait
partie mais ça mes prérogatives et des
pouvoirs j'ai j'ai donc eu plus qu'un
vite et inciter à ce qu'il y ait des
rapprochements il faut absolument que
tous les intervenants puissent
travailler ensemble de façon bien plus
bien plus serrée il ne peut être traité
cette question de la lutte contre les
violences conjugales c'est un
contentieux prioritaire malheureusement
un contentieux de masse il ne peut être
traité que par des violences individuel
en faisant toujours du sur mesure j'ai
envie de dire du cousu main et ça
nécessite bien sûr une mobilisation de 2
de tous les instants de tous les acteurs
judiciaires
bon je veux leur donner les moyens
d'agir et j'ai décidé de prévoir des
emplois publics spécifiques dédiés à ce
contentieux dans les juridictions parce
que j'ai demandé à ce qu'il y ait un
référent par par juridiction pour pour
traiter justement pour coordonner ces
informations qui ne sont pas
suffisamment diffusé et les parquetiers
monde y met
vous êtes bien gentil monsieur le garde
des sceaux mais on a un manque de moyens
de personnel donc on a doté les plus
gros juridiction d'un référent et on est
en train de avec la dsj de doter les
autres juridictions d'un référent pour
qu'il y ait au sein de chaque parc est
quelqu'un dont entre autres choses mais
mais mais spécifiquement sur ce thème
qui est le nôtre
quelqu'un qui puisse répondre
immédiatement et était assurée cette
coordination dont on voit tellement le
manque dans les différentes inspections
que j'ai que genii ordonnée et qu'il me
paraissait nécessaire nécessaire
d'ordonner 55 juriste assistant qui
seront déployés sans délai pour traiter
les violences conjugales
ils sont accompagnés de renforts humains
peuvent saisonniers pour instruire des
dossiers qui sont en attente parce que
là aussi j'ai demandé à ce qu'on aille
regarder puisque c'est ya parfois là la
question de la récidive
en tous les cas de la réitération en
tous les cas de signes de signaux forts
qui sont des plaintes déjà déposées qui
n'ont pas forcément abouti mais il ya
quelque chose
moi j'ai demandé à ce que ces
renseignements ce que c'est aux
comptablement à ce que ces
renseignements là soient prises en
considération tant qu'il ya tout un
travail d'archivés que j'ai demandé aux
parquets et c'est à cette occasion
qu'ils vont animer qu'il faudrait que on
nous donne un coup de main et je les ai
suffisamment entendu deuxième
volet de notre réunion de ce soir là la
prostitution alors me saisissant de la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
vous dresser un bilan d'étape de la loi
du 13 avril 2016 qui vise à renforcer la
lutte contre ce système prostitutionnel
et et accompagner les personnes
prostituées et vous m'interrogez plus
précisément sur la mise en place prévue
par cette loi
les commissions départementales de lutte
contre la prostitution en regrettant
qu'elle ne soit pas plus déployé sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
si je vous ai bien entendu un après
d'abord le saluent l'apport de ces
commissions qui prennent en charge des
victimes et qui ont permis de développer
les parcours de sortie de la
prostitution dont le taux de réussite
s'élève aujourd'hui à 95% pourtant c'est
mes services ont diffusé dès le 18 avril
une circulaire le politique pénale afin
que les parquets sont pas au plus vite
et au mieux des dispositions de cette
loi
je me dois de vous rappeler que ces
commissions sont présidées par le préfet
sur lequel je n'ai aucune merci madame
la présidente de rappeler ces évidences
et elle ne relève donc pas d'une
déclinaison de politique pénale
vous dressez également le constat d'un
investissement perfectible les
juridictions dans la pénalisation des
clients de la prostitution est
saisissant notamment du recours à la
nouvelle infraction d'achat d'actes
sexuels alors le constat que que vous
faites doit être me semble-t-il
relativiser puisque ans entre 2016 et
les condamnations ont augmenté de 44%
condamnation pour toi tu des êtres
humains
et 2 68% pour les condamnations du chef
de proxénétisme et sur cette même
période 2016 2019
72% des condamnations pour ces deux
délits tels emprisonnement ferme pour un
canton moyen de 24 - pour la traite des
êtres humains
29 points pour le proxénétisme j'ai bien
dit moyens évidemment
preuve s'il en est et services d'
enquêtes et les juridictions sont
investis dans la prise en compte de ce
contentieux
le taux de relaxer et globalement faible
moins de 10% en matière de traite des
êtres humains 5,2 pour cent en matière
de proxénétisme je le dis de façon tout
à fait anecdotique
ça n'est pas j'exprime sur 7 sur ce
point voici quelques regrets que ce soit
quand ya un doute il nous a
naturellement profité à l'accusé en
dépit de certaines choses que j'ai pu
lire être certaines propositions qui ont
été faites je ferme rapidement cette
parenthèse qui mérite de l'être
enfin s'agissant des poursuites pour
l'infraction de recours à la
prostitution d'autrui le nombre de
condamnations est passé de 440 en 2017 à
751 en 2010
enfin lorsque le maillage associatif le
permet les parcs et accroissant
progressivement le recours aux stages de
sensibilisation à la lutte contre l'
achat d'acte sexuel à titre
d'alternative aux poursuites pénales
les stages de sensibilisation à la
chatte acte sexuel constituait 29% des
poursuites en 2017
il constitue 36% des poursuites en 2020
je rejoins cependant votre constat du
phénomène particulièrement s'inquiétant
de la recrudescence de la prostitution
des mineurs on ressent ce 400 mineurs
victimes de proxénétisme en 2020
116 en 2016 en 5 ans une progression
terrifiante de 70% et il est observé que
les victimes de la prostitution sont
très majoritairement des jeunes filles
15 17 ans en moyenne
vulnérable évidemment provenant tous
milieux sociaux qui ont des difficultés
à prendre conscience de leur statut de
victime nous le savons nous avons
longuement échangé discuté avec les
sénateurs les députés bien sûr sur eux
cette fois billon qui nous a
enthousiasmés et nous avons
effectivement pour réfléchir à ces
questions nous allons entrer un crime
bien ces jeunes femmes peuvent refuser
ou cessa l'une des difficultés toute
collaboration avec les forces de l'ordre
tout placement pour mise à l'abri et les
dépôts de plaintes sont rarissimes
les réseaux qui les exploitent se
structure se professionnalise et il
s'appuie très massivement sur le cyber
et face à l'ampleur de ce phénomène d'un
groupe de travail dédié à la lutte
contre la prostitution des mineurs
piloté par la procureur général de paris
a été mise en place en octobre 2020 ce
groupe vient de rendre son rapport final
à cause qu'internet a chargé de
l'enfance et des familles avec de
nombreuses préconisations qui feront
l'objet d'un suivi interministériel pour
la mise en oeuvre et je veux rappeler
l'engagement de mon ministère pour
protéger les mineurs victimes contre
toutes les formes de violence sexuelle
j'ai pris une dépêche
le 8 février 2021 pour appeler au point
qu'il y aura la nécessité de mettre en
place une prise en charge spécifique les
mineurs victimes de traite des êtres
humains
le ministre de la justice soutient la
création d'un premier centre sécurisé
afin d'accueillir des mineurs victimes
de traite des êtres humains qui
bénéficiant d'un suivi renforcé en
termes d'éducation d'accompagnement
psychologique judiciaire et sanitaires
ce centre d'hébergement géré par
l'association kutxa seront en mesure
d'accueillir douze jeunes mineurs et
jeunes majeurs jusqu'à 21 ans
par ailleurs le ministère a fait le
choix de demander à tous les parcs et
une actualisation de situations berceau
en matière proxénétisme de cyber
proxénétisme est institutions des
mineurs l'analyse de ces retours est
actuellement en cours enfin vous avez
voté à l'unanimité la loi du 21 avril
2021 visant à protéger les mineurs de
crimes et délits sexuels et de l'ain
c'est ce qui nous a permis de réprimer
le recours à la prostitution des mineurs
de moins de 15 ans comme un viol de
définir d'abord de créer ce lien et est
naturellement de le réprimer comme un
viol soyez donc assuré la présidente
madame la sénatrice messieurs les
sénateurs de l'engagement sans faille de
mon ministère dans la lutte contre ce
phénomène d'ampleur et je me tiens
naturellement à votre disposition pour
toutes les questions ou voudrais bien me
poser merci monsieur le ministre mais
terminer sur cette proposition de loi
qui est devenu une loi vous n'avez pas
d'eau par donc ici et je tiens à
signaler que c'est vrai que nous avons
réussi à travailler avec le parlement et
avec le gouvernement pour que cette
proposition de loi devienne une loi le
22 avril 2021 et je tiens à vous
remercier personnellement du travail
qu'on a pu mener ensemble sur mon texte
de départ concernant la prostitution
juste peut être venir on sait
qu'aujourd'hui à 40000 personnes en
situation de prostitution environ 1300
verbalisation
donc on se dit bien qu' on a dû des
progrès à faire quant à la verbalisation
concernant l'est également lé parquet
spécialisé
je reste persuadé que les magistrats
sont oui en capacité de traiter ces
affaires
après on constate régulièrement une
sensibilité nécessaire pour bien aborder
les violences faites aux femmes les
violences intrafamiliales les violences
faites aux enfants lorsqu'il s'agit
d'identifier l'emprise notamment c'est
une véritable question aussi de volonté
d'engagement et de compréhension et je
vais juste faire une dernière remarque
sur le cloisonnement et le travail en
silo lorsqu'il ya eu le grenelle qui a
été lancé par le gouvernement certains
membres de la délégation avaient mené
des tables rondes dans leur département
et le constat était assez cruel de
découvrir qu'on mettait des gens autour
de la table qui travaillaient
normalement à la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes et qui se
découvrait presque avec des outils dont
ils disposaient chacun qui n'était
absolument pas partager donc bien
entendu je vous rejoins sur ce constat
monsieur le ministre mais je ne vais pas
être plus longs pour laisser la parole
aux nombreux collègues sénateurs et
sénatrices qui sont présents cet après
midi j'ai déjà de nombreuses
inscriptions
donc je vous propose de prendre deux ou
trois sénateurs intérêts questions de
sénateurs à la fois et je vous laisserai
répondre par bloc comme ça on va
progresser tranquillement je vais
immédiatement monsieur mini céder la
parole à notre collègue laurence
rossignol
ensuite dominique vais rien et laurence
cohen et ensuite je vous laisserai
répondre et on passera un autre bloc si
vous le permettez
si monsieur le garde des sceaux pour
votre nouveau chiffre en particulier
je voulais revenir peut-être sur
quelques sujets et je vais partir de la
question des juridictions spécialisées
et je veux insister sur l'articulation
qui lie à entre justice civile et
justice pénale en matière de prévention
de lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes et les violences faites aux
enfants qu'on pourra qu on peut
qualifier de violences intrafamiliales
en fait dans les nombreux comme comme
les féminicides ont acquis une
visibilité qu'il n'avait pas auparavant
sont sortis de la page des faits divers
pour venir dans les futilités violence
systémique
on connaît mieux les espèces a ajouté me
connais mieux les cas à chaque fois et
on est instruit on se rend compte que
beaucoup de féminicide j'ai pas fait le
calcul il est temps pour avoir la
proportion sont liées à des situations
de rupture de rupture de couple
c'est à dire que on a des féminicides
qui sont des bouts de l'aboutissement de
violences quotidiennes et répété et qui
finissent par un meurtre et pionnat une
part importante qu'ils sont liés aux
situations de rupture et donc les
situations de rupture elle se nouent et
se dénouent 1 où se dénoue dans le
cabinet du juge aux affaires familiales
le plus souvent quand tu es quand les
couples y sont passés il ya aussi des
couples qui ne qui ne passe pas et
l'intérêt la juridiction spécialisée
même si vous dites et j'ai envie de
penser comme vous que tous les juges
sont en situation de traiter les
violences intrafamiliales pour autant
l'analyse de jugement civil de
séparation ne dis pas ça toujours et il
ya des situations de violence qui sont
pas identifiés dans le cabinet du juge
aux affaires familiales
et il ya surtout à côté des féminicides
parce que je couche je pense que des
féminicides nous mobilise mais à
l'ensemble des violences qui ça compte
qu'ils ne vont heureusement va tout
jusqu'au meurtre ou assassinat mais qui
sont aussi des violences liées
à la séparation et celles ci sont pas
toujours bien prise en compte bien
appréhender et il ya une forme de
violence institutionnelle à l'encontre
des femmes qui s'exerce dans dans la
judoka grenat justice civile et
l'intérêt de l'espagne
outre ce que vous avez évoqué sur les
les grilles de référencement des
situations de dangerosité
c'est aussi justement de traiter les
deux est de décloisonner justice civile
et justice et justice pénale dans une
forme de prévention et à ce propos je
voudrais vous demander si vous pourriez
être plus insistant auprès de nos juges
et en particulier du juge aux affaires
familiales pour que la notion de sape de
syndrome de d'aliénation parentale
disparaissent des jugements de divorce
parce que elle le simple fait partie des
outils des violences contre les femmes
et je vais revenir aussi ce que lorsque
nous ont appris les différents cas qu'on
est content on a eu connaissance est sur
une série de propositions qui avait été
discuté au sénat
boncompain malheureusement pas été
retenu qui concerne la nécessité de
protéger la mise à l'anonymat quasiment
des femmes
une fois qu'elles sont partis je
regrette qu'on n'ait pas par exemple
dans l' ordonnance de protection qu'on
n'ait pas retenu le fait qu'on ne fut qu
on ne peut pas donner aux pères
l'adresse de l'école des enfants alors
me répond toujours wimille à l'autorité
parentale et donc il a droit sa roseraie
un enfant en fait comment vous dire ça
pèse pas lourd
le droit du père à l'autorité parentale
exercer une autorité parentale et quand
il se sert des enfants pour mener ces
des mères et des enfants donc je pense
qu'on pourrait aller plus loin dans la
protection de
l'anonymat de résidence des victimes
quitte à priver effectivement les perde
une partie de l'exercice dans votre tête
et par an tan les malheureux ça c'était
deux principales on remarque que je
voulais faire sur la manière dont on
peut encore progresser sur la prévention
de ces violences et ça c'est jessy turn
ans de protection mais on peut aussi en
parler une fois que leur danse
protection élevée et qu'on est dans
l'implication dans ces violences est ce
que vous pensez pas qu'il serait temps
aussi de revoir le droit de visite et
d'hébergement d'un côté et qu'il n'est
pas un qui n'est qu'un droit que les
pères exupère gillet pensait plus
souvent le cas exercent ou non puisque
les droits on a le journal options et le
devoir de représentation d'enfant des
mères il ya là une grande inégalité
puisque le jeudi pour les collègues qui
se créent ne maîtriseraient pas tout
toute l'histoire c'est que le droit de
visite et d'hébergement c'est le droit
de garde du week-end ou des vacances
c'est un droit on l'exercé selon lé père
vienne n'ont cherché des enfants ne en
général pour continué de harceler la mer
ils viennent pas les chercher pour
l'empêcher d'avoir une vie pendant les
week-ends en question quand il ya des
sujets mais en revanche lorsqu'une mère
n'est pas en situation de présenter
l'enfant au père c'est un devoir qui l'a
conduit systématiquement
systématiquement en correctionnelle avec
et comme il est comme on est dans une
procédure de citations directes
elle est systématiquement condamné
j'avais proposé qu' on réforme le droit
enfin ceux là nos rôles de non
représentation d'enfant parce que c'est
un outil des violences exercées contre
les femmes par les pairs voilà ces
diverses questions que je me posais ça
nous obligerait à revenir devant le
parlement
bon mais en fin de compte a sion le fait
que d'affaires en affaires de
compréhension collective on comprend
sans collective il faut en permanence
continuer d'améliorer la loi
je ne serai peut-être ma collègue
laurence cohen sûr
la loi de 2016 son application juste
pour faire une remarque qu'on ne pourra
pas on ne pourra pas réduire la
prostitution des mineurs si on n'a pas
une action beaucoup plus ferme à l'égard
des clients des procédés la prostitution
des majeures ce que vous raconte les
policiers ou les gendarmes qui ont
auditionné les gamines c'est que les
gamines nordiste bas c'est leur droit
elles font ce qu'elles veulent leur
corps et s'ils veulent se prostituer à
14 ans c'est un droit
et si tu es quand on a 14 ans on pense
que faire comme ce comme ce qu'on fait
quand on est grand ça vous fait grandir
et tant qu'on continuera de dire ou
d'être complaisant à l'égard des gens
qui pensent que la prostitution est une
liberté
un droit qui empiète sur une autre
liberté qu'est celle des clients on ne
pourra pas convaincre les gamines que à
14 ans et pas être grande que de se
prostituer et je pense qu'on est en deçà
en matière de mobilisation sur
l'application de l'ouest 2016 et en
particulier la pénalisation et de la
chasse aux clients jetés très clairement
moi je suis clean moi je suis cliente au
feu ben voilà puisqu'il faut pas rigoler
je suis pas plutôt folk comme j'entends
parfois je suis cliente octobre
incontestablement et je sais que c'est
tout dépend de la mobilisation des
parquets et là monsieur le garde des
sceaux j'ai connu des parcs est très
mobilisée pour l'application web 2016 et
qu'avec des résultats importants et des
parcs et et à des tas de par un des
nombreux parcs et dans lesquels
indépendamment des commissions de suivi
il n'y a pas de mobilisation
donc c'est vraiment à la main des
procureurs que d'utiliser le web 2016
admin ima pour protéger les mineurs
faute de convaincre tout le monde de
l'intérêt pour toute la société de
mettre fin à l'achat de services sexuels
merci chers collègues je fais passer la
parole à dominique vais rien et c'est
vrai que sur les 1300 verbalisation
auquel je faisais référence tout à
l'heure ce sont essentiellement des
verbalisations parisienne je le répète
chers collègues à vous merci beaucoup
mais la présidente
merci monsieur le ministre
je souhaiterais moins revenir sur leur
usage des armes à feu la problématique
des armes à feu qui joue bien souvent un
rôle central dans les féminicides comme
par exemple à monéteau dans l'yonne
récemment au mois de février dernier
vous avez avec gérald darmanin et marc
benchiha pas donné pour instruction la
saisie systématique des armes à feu et
cela dès le dépôt de plainte
qu'en est il aujourd'hui dans
l'exécution de cette décision et les
juges se pose-t-il systématiquement la
question de la présence ou non d'armes à
feu au domicile dans un département
rural comme les lionnes je peux vous
dire qu'il ya à peu près au moins autant
de fusil que deux chasseurs et ça fait
donc pas mal d'armes à feu et je sais
que quand ils sont saisis
souvent il est ordonné de les rendre
dans les quinze jours ce qui rend
l'homme tout autant dangereux mais
jusqu'à un jour après ensuite alors j'ai
aussi un courrier je voulais du coup
avoir une confirmation il semblerait que
l'appel d'offres du ministère de la
justice pour la prise en charge des
numéros fer destiné aux victimes le 116
00 6 prévoit une limitation de la durée
des conversations téléphoniques sous
peine de pénalités financières c'est
important parce que jusqu'à présent il y
avait bien des objectifs de durée mais
sans aucune pénalité
or là il semblerait qu'à l'avenir 80% de
ses communications devrait être de jeudi
parviennent au conditionnel c'est une
vraie question devrait être d'une durée
inférieure à six minutes et les 20%
restants devant être plafonnés à 9
minutes sous peine là encore deux
pénalités financières donc c'est une
disposition qui paraît très surprenante
surtout lorsque l'on sait qu'un appel
dure en moyenne aujourd'hui dix minutes
puisque enfin la moyenne est peut-être
inférieur mais on sait qu'il ya aussi
des appels raccrocher et c'est donc un
véritable une véritable conversation
c'est plutôt autour de 10 minutes et en
six minutes
il s'agir
pour une victime de violences sexuelles
ou d'attentats par exemple d'expliquer
sa situation de demander de l'aide dans
le même temps les coûts tant lui devra
établir une relation avec la personne
l'écouté répondre à ces questions de la
construire
le conseiller l'orienter vers une des
structures adéquates
donc s est ce exact qu'il y aura cette
limitation et des pénalités financières
si jamais ces temps ne sont pas
respectées merci chers collègues j'ai
passé la parole à laurence cohen oui
merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le ministre déjà il ya vous
avez toute une série de questions je
trouve qui cerne un peu plus encore la
problématique
moi je voudrais poursuivre sur 7 sur
cette lancée et quand même continuer à
nous poser ensemble la question des
tribunaux spécialisés parce que je pense
que l'exemple de l'espagne est un est un
exemple tout à fait tout à fait
intéressant même après si les choses ne
sont pas à calquer évidemment d'un pays
à l'autre parce qu'il ya une histoire il
ya une voie là il ya des choses qui sont
différentes mais je trouve que c'est
très important et qu'en tout cas il me
semble que ça serait un point d'appui
qui faciliterait l'articulation vraiment
entre le civil et le pénal vous l'avez
dit il il ya des ya des difficultés il
ya des manques d'articulation mais par
exemple on voit bien dans nos
territoires et je crois que vous l'avez
dit d'ailleurs dans votre propos
introductif qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
communication par exemple entre le jaf
et le procureur et que alors c'est pas
je généralise en disant ça c'est pas
tout les ja c'est pas tous les
procureurs bien évidemment il faut il
faut raison garder mais en tout cas
entre beaucoup de jaf et de procureurs
et donc sa classe et ses problématiques
et notamment quand il s'agit de décider
des droits de visite ont moins je vous
demande quand même à la lumière de
nos interventions de réfléchir à cette
question des tribunaux spécialisés et
d'ailleurs c'est pas seulement quelque
chose qui émergent dans les rangs de
quelques parlementaires de toutes
sensibilités politiques d'ailleurs c'est
vraiment une revendication des
associations féministes qui s'occupe des
victimes qui sont donc deux victimes de
violence et je pense que c'est important
mahama mon autre questionnement c'est
quand même on en a pas parlé
je pense que vous ne pouvez que
souscrire au fait que la justice a
besoin de moyens supplémentaires pour
faire face à ces missions est par
exemple si on ne prend que enfin ce qui
est un énorme problème et le problème
qui nous nous regardent aujourd'hui à
savoir les violences qui sont faites aux
femmes
on constate tout et tout ce qu'il y a
une aura une lenteur des enquêtes duran
duran d'ailleurs qui durent des mois et
que tant qu'il ne tant que par exemple
le le harceleur n'a pas été entendu et
bien il n'y a pas de protection des
victimes ce qui les met donc en danger
et elle doit faire comme si de rien
n'était et continuer y compris à croiser
à côtoyer le harceleur donc il me semble
que c'est un élément important et
j'aimerais vous entendre sur sur cette
question autre problématique une victime
ne peut pas se présenter dans une jeune
fille sans avoir déposé plainte donc y
compris pour faire donc constater les
liaisons or et vous l'avez rappelé à
juste titre seulement 10% des femmes
déposent plainte
dans d'autres pays il n'y a pas cette
nécessité de déposer plainte pour avoir
recours à lui mjs qui ne ne peut pas y
avoir de votre part une modification
donc des règles du jeûne si je puis dire
qui permettraient
une simplification et de fait donc une
possibilité supplémentaire pour pour les
femmes de pouvoir avoir une réquisition
du parquet etc etc
mon autre mon autre questionnement c'est
concernant la définition des violences
et notamment je trouve que les violences
psychologiques ont du mal à être prises
en compte
donc est ce qu'il ne faut pas revoir
tout simplement leur leur définition
parce que c'est quelque chose qu'il a
aussi peut être un blocage pour faire
reconnaître donc le statut de victime au
niveau des femmes tout coeur tout comme
d'ailleurs la prise en compte des
définitions des violences économiques
quand on sait que 70 % des agresseurs
ont un emploi contre 40% des victimes
seulement et on sait très bien c'est
pour ça que je veux en parler avec vous
cet après midi on sait pertinemment que
ces conditions socio économiques vont
avoir un impact sur le droit de garde et
que donc on voit bien là toutes les
conséquences et les liens qui existent
au niveau y compris du chantage exercé
au niveau des hauts niveaux des femmes
enfin pour ne pas pour ne pas hausser
vous harcelez de trop de questions à mon
tour parce que je dis je dénonce le
harceleur et je ne voudrais pas être
harceleuse mais effectivement ma
collègue laurence rossignol en parler de
la loi de 2016 concernant la
prostitution c'est une bataille
importante que nous avons mené au niveau
des hémicycles
moi je voudrais avoir peut-être un
éclaircissement sur la sortie du
parcours de prostitution et notamment
nous avons été alertés en tant que
parlementaire sur des femmes qui on a
confisqué les proxénètes ont confisqué
les papiers qui se retrouve donc sans
papiers tributaire donc de ses bourreaux
et
il y a énormément de difficultés à
prendre en compte leurs paroles parce
que on a une certaine défiance à leur
égard et elles sont femmes elles sont
sans papiers elles sont victimes de la
prostitution est en moi j'ai entendu des
réponses me disant que finalement est
bien l été par derrière soutenu par des
proxénètes et finalement c'était un
moyen d'obtenir des papiers
donc là il ya aussi quelque chose à
revisiter de ce point de vue là pour
permettre à ces femmes de sortir de ce
parcours de prostituées de la
prostitution
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vais
éviter de harceler monsieur le ministre
et je vais le laisser répondre
immédiatement à ses trois premières
séries de questions puisque vous aurez
deux autres épisodes de derrière
monsieur le ministre
donc je vous laisse répondre à ces se
jettent question extrêmement précise et
intéressante
la triste rossignol qui me suggère
de bouger vous m'entendez pas oui qui
monsieur qui me suggère dizaines de
bouger un peu les juges aux affaires
familiales
nous sommes dans l'hérésie madame la
sénatrice vous savez que dire et on est
si je demandais un juge du siège ou au
juge du siège au pluriel d'ailleurs de
bouger quoi que ce soit vrai quel point
les magistrats ils ont raison d'ailleurs
son sont soucieux de leur indépendance
là on est dans du jury sionnel pur
je suis d'accord pour réfléchir avez
vous sur l'action d'anonymat ça me
parait il faut protéger les victimes et
au-delà de la condamnation de du
conjoint violent qui parfois n'est pas
lourdement coup de condamner où il est
condamné à l'aune de d'un premier fai
qui peut être qualifié violences légères
tout le savons bon il ya toujours ce
risque
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
que nous puissions échanger sur ces sur
ces questions s'agissant des violences
le droit de visite et d'hébergement
je compte vous dire que tant au civil
qu'au pénal le juge peut intervenir sur
l'autorité parentale et
vous avez adopté de loi décembre 2019 30
juillet 2020 qui ont tiré les
conséquences de l'impact de ces
violences sur les enfants en modifiant
les règles de retrait de l'autorité
parentale ou de son exercice afin de
protéger au plus vite sa famille ou
donner quelques chiffres
là encore c'est que c'est toujours
rébarbatif les chiffres mais le nombre
de mesures mois tirant l'autorité
parentale ou l'exercice de l'autorité
parentale en cas de violence conjugale
ne cesse d'augmenter en 2010 est
seulement neuf décisions ce sens en 2020
236 décision qui en retirer ou limiter
l'exercice de l'autorité parentale tokia
une véritable sensibilisation maintenant
à ces questions et sur le le problème
mais j'ai envie de dire pour être tout à
fait objectif le problème parfois pas
toujours de du manque de communication
entre entre le le juge civil et le juge
pénal
je suis allé à rouen récemment où
justement on a mis en place une fluidité
entre le civil et le pénal salle et
chacun est un peu dans son pré carré
ça tient aux habitudes se tient parfois
à une envie d'être très sourcilleux sur
son indépendance comprend des juges du
siège et c'est légitime mais il se met
en place ces échanges est d'ailleurs ce
que nous avons vu nous ne l'avons
intégrée dans les bonnes pratiques parce
que nous estimons que ce sont de bonnes
pratiques et je tiens ma disposition je
peux vous le remettre ce qui est fait à
valenciennes par exemple sur ces
questions cour d'appel de douai tribunal
judiciaire de valenciennes la politique
pénale en matière de lutte contre les
violences conjugales je vais vous
remettre ce document madame la
présidente c'est extrêmement intéressant
ce qui est fait et ça comment dirais je
mets l'accent sur la nécessité d échange
bon c'est le sens de la dépêche ddps que
j'ai pu prendre
on ne peut pas dire non plus parce que
ce ne serait pas le fruit delà de la
réalité que dans toutes les juridictions
ne se parle pas du tout mais on a
malheureusement al'expertise un autre
expertise récente d'ailleurs expertise
qui nous est livré par l'inspection
générale de la justice des expériences
des retours d'expérience on voit à
l'évidence que ça n'a pas fonctionné la
normalité c'est que ça fonctionne et que
ça échange il ya un certain nombre de
choses qui sont mises en place et on a
l'impression que je vous je vous donne
ce ne sera pas ouvert il est extrêmement
intéressant sur la suppression du but du
délit de non représentation d'enfant
moi je pense qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'aller jusque là le procureur peut
immédiatement être avertis du climat de
violence et ne pas poursuivre une femme
qui refuse nous dans les enfants parce
que si elle ne donne pas le mérite selon
le mari d'être pardon c'était sûr grect
citation directe c'est ça le problème en
dispense de peine
nous répondons mais mais mais pardon
mais pardon ça n'est pas suffisante
parce que il faut quand même aller
devant tribunal et la femme qui donne
pas ses mots parce qu'elle a peur de
recevoir une raclée le mérite pas
d'aller non plus vénal donc on peut
regarder ces questions je je je pense
que c'est pas trop compliqué sans nom
mais je vous crois je crois est
maintenant là encore il ya évidemment
c'est moi quand je dis que je défends la
justice de façon républicaine je le
défends ce de façon républicaine jamais
corporatiste ya effectivement des choses
qui sont choquantes quand on voit ça
comment on mérite pas d'aller au
tribunal dans ces situations là d'autant
qu'il ya une opportunité des poursuites
donc franchement échangeons sur ces
questions je pense qu'on peut régler ça
avec beaucoup de bon sens et et que
beaucoup de nos de nos procureurs
ont toutes les qualités pour régler ces
questions il l'humanité qui convient
dans ces situations particulières
je l'entends parfaitement ce que vous
dites et qu'on me dit que vous avez les
dossiers c'est qu'elle a se chausse
comme ça on était fait ouais une femme
doit pas trembler quand le dimanche soir
ou le samedi matin elles donnent pas les
gosses parce que elle a la conviction
qu'elle va se se prendre une dérouillée
je fais mais on est d'accord
moi j'en ai beaucoup je les passerai
votre cabinet bien volontiers puis elles
mêmes des avocats qui sont cons
travailler beaucoup là dessus
en fait c'est les enfants qui sont
victimes de violence chez le père et qui
ne votent plus y aller sur est une femme
quand vous voulez vous envoyer deux
grands ados de 14 ans par la force
passer le week-end chez son père frank
t'hézan peur et qui veulent pas y aller
c'est une singulière tenu parce que si
elle les yeux
il ya une forme de non assistance à
personne en danger d'un que non mais je
pense que ça peut être écouter un peu de
bon sens les mots justes je pense qu'on
peut régler ces questions et je pense
que les dossiers que vous évoquez sont
pas ne sont pas le fonctionnement
ordinaire de la justice mais sont sans
doute des dysfonctionnements il y
convient me semble-t-il de 10 mètres un
terme je pense qu'on peut le faire sans
sans aucune sans aucune difficulté
ensuite est revenu la question madame
madame la sénatrice cohen de l'espagne
et de l'exemple espagnol nous nous
n'avons pas expertisé qu'il serait utile
de créer des juridictions spécialisées
je vous dire que
l'espagne sans doute est à l'avant garde
de toutes ces questions et depuis depuis
depuis longtemps mais le maillage
territorial espagnol n'est pas le même
que le nôtre il faut aussi prendre en
considération à certain nombre de
différences de spécificités et je le
redis je leur dis mais je pense que tout
le monde peut l'entendre autant
techniquement par exemple en petit héros
la lutte antiterroriste nécessite une
juridiction spécialisée d'ailleurs la
création récente du parquet national
anti terroriste démontre à quel point
quand on voit son efficacité il était
nécessaire de créer donc d'ultra
spécialisés les magistrats qui traite de
cette question
autant là je pense que n'importe quel
est ce n'est pas désobligeants house
magistrat qui connaît la correctionnelle
par exemple où la cour d'assises sont un
crime très fait de ces affaires les
pères spécialisation soupe en jeu j'ai
un peu de mal à concevoir et à fondre
une spécialisation dans notre
architecture judiciaire française mais
là encore moi je sais je suis fermé à
rien si on donne une solution clé en
main et que et que je trouve bonne je
n'ai pas par principe
comment dirais-je 2
d'euros je pense qu'on peut évoquer la
question
vous m'avez également parlé de lui-même
j alors lui-même j on va rappeler on va
rappeler quand même que elle a pour
objet d'établir une preuve objective et
donc s'il n'y a pas de plainte c'est
compliqué c'est et moi non je voyais
élus mjc pas c'est pas lui mj qui doit
aller vers la victime servi team qui
doit aller vers lui angie avec une
plainte puisque le but de lui mjc ça en
revanche il ya des partenariats qui sont
mises en place entre les hôpitaux et les
umj mais on peut pas non plus de
dénaturer ce qu'est le huji c'est ça
peut alors peut-être moi j'en sais rien
comment on peut régler cette question
parce que est-ce que souvent d'aider la
victime si elle veut au fond que l'on
prenne en considération son préjudice ce
qu'elle subit que ça s'arrête etc
il faut quand même qu'elle fasse une
petite démarches judiciaires - dépôt de
plainte quelque chose est ce que vous
pourriez le penser c'est pas moi qui
vous intéresse le domaine ils ont plus
précise des choses qui fonctionnent pas
en fait si vous voulez vous et moi j'ai
été interpellé plusieurs fois par le
fait que en fait des femmes parce que
ils viennent de subir un choc terrible
je pense notamment à des viols
voilà elles sont montées thalys etc
elles elles ne vont pas jusqu'à aller
porter plainte mais par contre elles
peuvent aller essayer de faire constater
ce qu'elles ont ce qu'elles ont subis et
si vous voulez le fait qu'on puisse a en
fait c'est ça le fait qu'on puisse
constater
avec des preuves qui vont être prélevés
sur elle et qui peuvent être conservées
nouveau va leur permettre en réalité de
porter plainte peut-être en décalé et
utilisez donc basse les profs qu'on a
trouvé de l'agression et s'était rassuré
il ya des cas où il ya vraiment ce
décalage alors je ne sais pas si je
pense qu'il yad'autres d'autres
sénatrice que moi qui ont constaté on a
été alertée de la même façon dominique
koch la tête mais voilà c'est vraiment
moins des cas objectif qui qui existe
juste pour dire que chez nous à
l'hôpital il ya des dispositifs de pré
plainte
oui qui font tous les médecins se
saisissent quand même de la chose et
après la femme a du temps pour aller
porter plainte si les ssl simplement
même si n'apprécia il ya une trentaine
d'établissements réalité et ben on y
travaille
voilà un nom mais je comprends
exactement ce que ce que vous voulez
dire et on souhaite généraliser cette
possibilité mais il faut quand même
alors ça ça parle on peut pas y échapper
faux la présence de la victime
naturellement nom qui va se retrouver
dans une situation dans laquelle on va
essayer l'objectiver dédire qui seront
les siens mais qui ne seront pas
recueillies dans le cadre d'une plainte
alors l'intérêt aussi que présente le
fait de l'expertisé c'est que on peut
lui donner un certain nombre de conseils
naturellement et lui dire un certain
nombre de choses
je suis allé voir au cateau-cambrésis
quelque chose absolument extraordinaire
en affamés reçu allait d'abord visité
par les médecins ce qui est bien logique
quand on objective des coûts des
violences
elle est prise en charge ensuite par un
psychologue
puis par un assistant social parce que
l'on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure la
question des enfants est primordiale et
parfois on dépose plainte parce que il
ya qu'est ce qu'on va faire des enfants
puis il ya aussi un retentissement
économique que vous avez souligné qui
fait bouillir la marmite ce terrain
d'accord ensuite arrivés les gendarmes
tout ça dans le même mieux en en prenant
toutes les précautions inhérentes aux ce
club professionnel faire très attention
à tout ça
gendarmes le procureur arrive et même et
même en bout de course un avocat faire
que tout tout est fait au même endroit
avec des ch'ti ça moi je souhaite
l'encourager mais ça ça c'est de l'ordre
du partenariat c'est préfectoraux
préfectorale medica c'est un jeune
médecin qui a conçu sa au
cateau-cambrésis c'est un truc
absolument formidable est d'accord je je
comprends mieux la question je l'avais
mal comprise et on essaie effectivement
de généraliser ça pour le moment c'est
c'est trente 30 établissements qui le
font et pourrait qu'ils le fassent tous
évidemment
ensuite vous m'avez vous m'aviez pas de
protection son audition du conjoint
oui mais l' ordonnance de l'ordre dans
une protection un peu attendu dans les
six jours et c'est compliqué de prendre
une mesure qui est aussi une mesure de
coercition sans avoir entendu les
protagonistes parce que vous ne pouvez
pas exclure que 6 99% des plantes
correspondent à une réalité il ya un
pour cent de plaintes qui ne
correspondent pas une réalité vrai non
plus exclure intime de son domicile et
il suffirait alors de déposer une
plainte pour ce qu'ils soient dirais que
c'est lui voyez ce que je veux dire il
ya quand même ce risque là
judiciairement ne peux pas concevoir une
décision à intervenir sans entendre tous
toutes les parties d'un sceptre c'est
l'essence même de la justice qu de
respecter le contradictoire donc six
jours c'est c'est bon et six jours ça a
été ça a été retenu en expertise avec la
comment dirais-je le judiciaire de
terrain non elle je vois difficilement
comment on pourrait faire plus qu on
peut on peut demander si on peut faire
plus court mais je crains que ce disque
et on ne le dira nous manquons de moyens
mais à si je veux quand même sens
persiflé dire que certains
parlementaires n'ont pas voté le budget
l'année dernière en disant qu' il
n'était pas suffisamment ambitieux ce
qui est quand même assez singulier il ya
pas en cours d'année on démarré mais il
n'y a pas assez moyen c'est quand même
une augmentation historique 8% et le
budget a augmenté de 21% depuis la
mandature et je peux vous dire que en
matière civile comme en matière pénale
on envoyait beaucoup gens aux
juridictions et que ça aide et en
particulier en particulier dans le
traitement des violences faites aux
femmes
je pense à peu près avoir répondu
répondu à tout le monde non les
violences sur les vidéos sur l'aspect
violence psychologique gens pensent que
vous dites et d'air ça rejoint la
réflexion qui est la mienne sur les
enfants qui souvent sont victimes de
violence psychologique quand ils voient
comme ce qu'ils voient leur père bat
leur mère 7
c'est pour moi une violence intrinsèque
qui est infligé jeu je joue les leaders
je souhaite réfléchir sur ces questions
et voir comment on peut les les
l'ordonné qu'au fond ils s'arment a fait
le 116 oui oui pardon pardon pas son
temps donc il faut avoir dans t'es là ça
tiens ta nous avons des ordres d'abord
les armes à feu
celle qui a une une circulaire du mois
d'août où j'ai demandé au parquet de
saisir toutes les armes et
on est en train de travailler avec le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
pour avoir un fichier qui doit
restreindre mais façon drastique pour ne
pas dire qu'il veut interdire l'accès
aux armes pour les violents mari violent
et on vous proposera sa dans le goût
cadre le vecteur législatif est celui
qui va traiter de la responsabilité
pénale en particulier ce sont les
travaux que j'ai été amené à conduire
après l' affaire halimi on va étendre si
j'ose dire écarter un peu élargir un peu
le vecteur pour y mettre un certain
nombre de dispositions dont celle qui
vous préoccupe
pour qu'on soit très efficace au dessus
on est plus dans me traîner merci
monsieur le ministre on valide être
criel 116 0,06 alors le numéro 116 et
six minutes
oui je sais pas alors on fait attention
parce que sinon il y aura plus personne
à la fin il ya de nombreux collègues qui
ont demandé l'arrêt des interventions
également pensé à eux également
il est absolument inexact de dire que le
ministère de la justice pour la prise en
charge du numéro vert destiné aux
victimes prévoit une limitation de la
durée des conversations téléphoniques
sous peine de pénalités financières
france victime que j'ai reçues il ya peu
de temps me fait part d'un certain
nombre de difficultés
il ya en réalité
le but de cet appel est d'orienter mais
naturellement pas j'imagine qu'une femme
qui a été violée
on va pas lui dire appelé tel numéro
envoie madame surtout si elle est en
pleurs surtout si elle a du mal à
raconter son histoire mal surtout donc
il ya des temps moyen évidemment et
aucune disposition de l'appel d'offres
que ne prévoit la limitation de durée
d'appel on se réfère à des durées
moyennes
non ce qui autorise d'ailleurs des
appels qui dépasse 6 ou 9 minutes ans
j'ai lu un certain nombre de choses qui
sont pas l'exacte réalité sur cette
question et moi je serai très attentif à
ce que les victimes soient bien prises
en charge
ça me paraît quand même le b à ba c'est
le premier contact téléphonique
si on dit au bout de x temps va coûter
mal à me convainc pas le temps deux
piliers des gens qui ont besoin de deux
de contextualiser besoin d'être rassurés
ça me fait donc je suis attentif à cette
question j'ai j'ai d'ailleurs lu dans la
presse ça m'a fait très plaisir que
france victime disait que le ministre
avait été très attentif à ce qu'est ce
qu'elle disait peut tout à fait
légitimement je pense qu'humainement on
peut pas laisser ni croire ni ni ni ni
donc au moins faire en sorte que que les
victimes soient pas prises en charge
correctement dans sept 7 appellent donc
on y travaille on est en train de
regarder tout ça merci monsieur le
ministre alors pour que tout le monde
ait le temps de poser ces questions je
vais prendre un paquet dessus plus
m'exprimer ainsi de quatre sénateurs et
sénatrices
nadège est ensuite marie pierre monnier
jean michel arnaud et martine filleul et
je vous laisserai répondre et je
prendrai le dernier lot de sénateurs
ensuite donc nadège et merci pour la
concision des propos deux questions
courtes
en fait non c'est pas l'avion pour brest
mais j'ai voilà faut tout le monde
puisse voter ces questions nombre de
fans en fait victime de violences
conjugales voulant franchir la porte
d'un commissariat ou d'une brigade
craignent une confidentialité
insuffisantes ou tout simplement de ne
pas être prise au sérieux
pourriez-vous nous dire monsieur le
garde des sceaux et faire un point sur
l'état des lieux du point de vue de la
coordination entre les ministères et
entre les services sur le territoire sur
le terrain en fait lors du dépôt de
plainte et la seconde question fait il y
à peu vous avez avec votre collègue
marlène schiappa déclaré que dans une
tribune vouloir que 100 % des plaintes
soit prise qualifiée transmise au
parquet pour qu'ensuite la justice les
traite
pour ce faire il doit y avoir un volet
formation indispensable
où en est on sur ces sujets bien merci
chers collègues pour la précision et la
rapidité de ces questions je passais de
la parole tout de suite un mari pierre
monnier merci madame la présidente
bonjour monsieur le ministre
d'abord il ya eu donc un rapport remis
et des recommandations suite au
féminicide mérignac vous avez cité
quelques recommandations qui ont été
prises mais certaines n'ont pas été
reprises j'aimerais savoir pourquoi et
en particulier ce que vous comptez faire
pour que les victimes soient informés à
chaque stade de la procédure notamment
au moment pouvant être une source de
danger pour elle comme la remise en
liberté la liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire de leur agresseur présumé ou
la sortie de détention de l'auteur de
violences y en a deux autres ce qui
m'interpelle qui n'ont pas été reprises
c'est la fusion des listes des grilles
d'évaluation plus exactement au danger
avec la grille
l'évaluation aux victimes c'est à dire
ministère l'intérieur ministère de la
justice pourquoi est ce qu'elles peuvent
pas être fusionnées cela éviterait
peut-être une surcharge administrative
et parfois des difficultés d'évaluation
réel du danger serait écarté et il y en
a une troisième c'est le conditionnement
d'envoi législatives de tout aménagement
de peine concernant les auteurs de
violences conjugales grave à la
réalisation d'une expertise
psychiatrique ou médico psychologique
préalable
vous avez parlé de budget et vous avez
dit que la réponse fait la réponse quand
allez-vous faire c'est que le budget
n'est pas suffisant tout à l'heure vous
avez dit que vous allez faire un effort
supplémentaire au budget c'est vrai que
c'est une grande cause du quinquennat
ces violences fait de la lutte contre
ces violences faites aux femmes
vous dites que déjà le budget est
passablement augmenté mais j'attire
votre attention sur le fait que quelques
procureur que des procureurs il ya
quelques semaines ont quand même tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé sur la difficulté à
appliquer l'ensemble des circulaires
dispositif prévu par la loi pour lutter
contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles
donc vous nous avez un petit peu dit
qu'il y aura encore un effort
supplémentaire est ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire plus sur ce sujet je vais
profiter de votre venue pour vous parler
d'un cas très spécifique d'un exemple
local qui illustre à mon sens les uns
les impasses judiciaires dans lesquelles
se trouvent parfois les femmes victimes
de violences il s'agit du cas d'une
femme du cas d'une femme qui est victime
de violence qui bénéficie d'une
ordonnance de protection à l'encontre de
son conjoint et qui m'a amené à me poser
quelques questions d'une part sur le
fonctionnement même fonctionnement même
des ordonnances de protection
cette dernière interdit les interactions
mais elle n'empêche pas le conjoint
violent de se trouver à proximité ou
même de venir parler à leurs enfants
alors même qu'il n'a plus aucun droit
sur lui n'a plus l'autorité parentale
dans les faits cela ne suffit donc pas à
la mettre en sécurité
quelles évolutions du système judiciaire
pourrions nous envisager pour que les
injonction d'éloignement soient
privilégiés
au lieu et place des ordonnances de
protection et ensuite d'autre part dans
ce cas précis l'individu a enfreint une
ordonnance de protection
la femme a porté plainte et malgré un
contexte chargé avec un individu connu
des services de la justice et condamnés
à de la prison ferme pour des faits de
violence conjugale ni moins de deux ans
auparavant
ce dernier n'a eu qu'un simple rappel à
la loi c'est donc la victime qui suivit
le poids des angoisses notre impuissance
collective devant cette situation est
difficile
selon vous que faudrait-il faire pour
faire évoluer pour pouvoir apporter des
solutions aux femmes trop nombreuses qui
vivent des situations similaires
je ne peux pas terminer ça vous parlez
de la loi contre le système
constitutionnel juste vous dire que moi
c'était pratiquement mes débuts au sénat
que c'est une loi qui était difficile à
être votées et qui d'ailleurs n'a pas
été voté au sénat en l'état et que
vraiment je crois que vous avez engagé
une réflexion sein de votre ministère
suite à la publication d'un rapport qui
avait été fait je crois en 2019 est ce
que vraiment je moi je rejoins tout à
fait celle qui se sont exprimées avant
moi que la pénalisation du client
c'était un sujet qui avait fait beaucoup
débat
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire
vraiment en sorte que cette loi soit
appliquée merci merci chers collègues
donc tout de suite
jean michel arnaud et ensuite martine
filleul et je vous laisserai répondre
monsieur le ministre est une femme un
président que nous avons menées durant
cette session
tout un travail sur la question que la
vie de la femme en ruralité et quand on
regarde les féminicides où on se rend
compte que plus de la moitié des
féminicides ont lieu en milieu rural
nous avons également 12 % seulement des
femmes victimes de violence qui porte
plainte en milieu rural contre 30% ville
les femmes subissant des violences en
milieu rural ont des conditions
évidemment d'accès à leurs droits
beaucoup plus difficile qu'en zone
urbaine
le fait qu'on ait un maillage
effectivement de gendarmerie ou de
police sur tous les sans abri en zone
rurale relativement peu compact la
difficulté évidemment de la connaissance
des droits de ces femmes la difficulté
de connaissance du numéro d'appel le 39
19 et est parfois tout simplement un an
que de connexion numérique qui ne permet
pas aux femmes en milieu rural de
pouvoir se met dans un pot retour de
parcours de protection je me permets
d'insister sur deux sujets sur lequel
j'aimerais avoir de votre part une
réaction je l'espère la plus précise
possible mais a été fait religieux toler
essentiellement aux zones urbaines à lui
m j je tiens à vous indiquer que dans
certains départements de france nous
n'avons pas à ce jour deux médecins
légistes de plein exercice permettant
d'évaluer dans de bonnes conditions les
incapacités de travail et donc d'avoir
ensuite un processus notamment réponses
pénales ou civiles à due proportion
puisque les premières heures sont
évidemment déterminante pour connaître
le niveau de violence commis sur les
victimes
qu'en est il du déploiement dans tous
les départements de france et je
prendrai un exemple département des
hautes-alpes que je représente ici qui
n'a pas à ce jour deux médecins légistes
à même de pouvoir faire ce travail et je
le tiens évidemment des magistrats et du
parking particulier qui se trouvent
confrontés à de graves difficultés pour
accompagner les femmes victimes
la deuxième question précise
c'est me semble-t-il l'utilité aussi de
développer des maisons d'accueil
d'hommes violents
dans les départements pour un suivi et
un accompagnement des auteurs de
violences est également une meilleure
protection des victimes
il est quand même inacceptable que je
sois en jaune urbaine ou en zone rurale
que la victime de violence sont obligés
de quitter le lieu de vie traditionnel
et notamment aux zones rurales bien
souvent la victime est également une
femme agricultrice qui ne peut pas
quitter à la fois son domicile et son
travail puisqu'elle est bien souvent
associée dans le gaec de l'exploitation
donc je pense indispensable de pouvoir
effectivement développé et ne répondait
pas simplement vous y travailler mais
j'aimerais effectivement que nous
puissions avoir un déploiement avec un
planning un peu précis sur ce type
d'offre de protection et
d'accompagnement et donc ça va de pair
évidemment avec le réseau associatif qui
est bien souvent concentrés dans les
zones et dans les départements ruraux
dans les centres bourgs ou ou au mieux
dans la préfecture de chef lieu ce qui
est évidemment insuffisant pour pour
accompagner dans les meilleures
conditions les victimes de violence je
vous remercie
merci cher collègue martine filleul oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre merci d'avoir répondu déjà
attendre de deux questions cela va
rendre mon intervention beaucoup
beaucoup plus courte
rassurez-vous et elle va concerner les
moyens consacrés à la lutte contre la
prostitution
j'ai cru comprendre que vous partagiez
notre constat d'une d'une prostitution
qui a beaucoup évolué et par conséquent
je pense que vous partagez aussi le
constat que nous vous avions transmis
dans le courrier à auquel annick billon
a fait référence qu'il fallait
absolument s'adapter adapter nos
réponses en conséquence de la chaîne
pénale à l'accompagnement des victimes
cela suppose bien évidemment des moyens
supplémentaires des moyens humains des
moyens financiers or je voulais
vous vous rappelez j'ai beaucoup
d'audace que la loi de 2016 a prévu de
confisquer les biens des proxénètes et
que cela a rapporté la coquette somme de
10 millions d'euros en 2019 et qu'il
s'avère qu'il n'ya que je crois deux
millions et demi deux millions et demi
qui sont réinjectés dans
l'accompagnement dans la politique
d'accompagnement des victimes
est ce que vous ne pensez pas monsieur
le ministre qu'il serait légitime que
ces 10 millions d'euros ou plus
éventuellement soient réinjectées dans
la politique de lutte contre la
prostitution
voilà merci de répondre à cette question
qui peut apparaître anecdotique mais qui
me semble importante au moment où on
chante on cherche beaucoup de moyens si
chers collègues je vous laisse répondre
et ensuite y aura trois autres questions
monsieur le ministre
ou vous préférez content même toutes les
questions non c'est bon ok donc je vous
laisse répondre monsieur mistris ne des
jeux avait sur la question de la
formation évoqué la missive a évoqué
ouais elle a évoqué la question de la
formation veut dire que le nm à
renforcer la formation des magistrats
aux spécificités des violences
conjugales
ce qui fait écho avec ce dont nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure de deux
juridictions spécialisées mais l'école
nationale de la magistrature a été
attentive à ce que il y est une
formation particulière parce qu'il ya
effectivement un certain nombre de
spécificités même si j'ai déjà dit
pardon je répète pour la troisième fois
d'un point de vue technique ce n'est pas
l'antiterrorisme répond on à l'antique
la formation de l'onem a donné un
caractère interprofessionnel au cours
qui ont été qui ont été dispensés là
encore pour mobiliser très largement et
plus puissamment les différents acteurs
qui interviennent
il ya en ligne un kit de formation
pédagogique avec des fiches qui sont des
fiches si j'ose dire réflexe par
fonction des interviews des vidéos
d'experts sur les mécanismes de
l'emprise de temps dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure puisque l'on me disait mémé
les juridictions spécialisées pourrait
mieux prendre en considération ces vous
madame la présidente d'ailleurs qui le
disiez tout à l'heure dans également
organisation de formations délocalisées
auprès des cours d'appel ouverte aux
magistrats tous les acteurs locaux
investis dans le domaine à grasse par
exemple le 11 juin 100 professionnels
ont été réunies magistrats avocats
policiers gendarmes conseillers
pénitentiaires d'insertion et probation
travailleurs sociaux représentants des
associations d'aidé aux victimes ou
suivi des auteurs
et le matin était consacré à la
sensibilisation sur les notions
d'emprise et le pic autrement l'après
midi petits groupes autour de cas
pratiques donc tout cela évidemment me
semble-t-il répond à vos interrogations
légitimes coordination dépôt de plainte
brest un travail constant des départs
kuti des procureurs qui organise
notamment la relecture des mains
courantes par les services pour ne pas
qu'il y ait on dit aujourd'hui je dis
que cette expression de trous dans la
raquette est assez signifiante même s'il
n'est pas gracieuse mais voilà c'est de
faire en sorte
et puis naturellement vous m'avez posé
l'action devrait interpeller sur les
forces de sécurité intérieures ça ce
n'est pas mon périmètre mais je crois
pouvoir dire sont dénaturés la vérité
que beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits et
un certain nombre d'affaires qui ont
démontré que ça n'était pas toujours
prises en compte
voilà pas prise en charge certain nombre
de dossiers
nous avons encore à l'esprit ce bon je
pense que je pense que le militant
l'intérieur a donné un certain nombre de
véritables consignes pour ne pas que
visa monde et des plaintes des alertes
soient laissées sans réponse
madame la sénatrice monnier double
interpellé sur les recommandations sont
celles de l'inspection générale de la
justice après l affaire de mérignac
inspection que j'ai que j'ai appelé de
mes voeux que nous avons appelé nos yeux
c'est une inspection commune vous vous
le savez ministère de l'intérieur
ministère de la justice première
recommandation c'est conditionné par
voie législative le prononcé de tout
aménagement de peine concernant les
auteurs vous vous l'avez rappelé tout le
concernant les auteurs de violences
conjugales grave à la réalisation d'une
expertise psychiatrique ou musicaux psy
c'est à l'expertisé peux pas vous en
dire plus pour le moment
recommandation numéro de modifier la loi
801 systématiser l'information des
victimes lorsque l'auteur des faits
s'est déjà fait je vais demander par des
pêches du 19 mai 2021
j'ai demandé à ce que donne cette
information qui me paraît capital à la
victime sur la date de libération de
l'auteur c'est quand même bien loin
parce que ce serait extraordinaire que
que cette femme qui a été menacée ne
sache pas bon c'était une évidence et
jeu
je lui ai demandé et je suis en train de
regarder la possibilité d'être ondes
d'étendre sa par décret par voie de
décret et enfin vous me demandez c'est
une c'est une autre recommandation
d'ailleurs recommandation numéro 5 qui
préconise l'ancien travail conjoint en
vue de fusionner la grille d'évaluation
du danger et la grille de v
vie et moi je suis fait avoir là
certains comme nation il ya un travail
de coordination et d'harmonisation des
grilles et des pratiques sur tout le
territoire
ça me semble tout à fait nécessaire pour
une évaluation efficiente des besoins de
protection
monsieur le sénateur jean michel arnaud
on a mis en place des juridictions mis
en place le disais tout à l'heure des
systèmes permettant aux victimes
bon on en milieu rural d'être mise en
relation directe avec des associations
de victimes et dead et on le fait par la
visioconférence alors je suis allé dans
différentes juridictions
évidemment ces bonnes pratiques ont été
diffusées par le truchement notamment de
l'impro net dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
et alors je j'ai vu comment une
gendarmerie qui reçoit ni team là mais
en visio directement en relation avec
l'association locale qui va la prendre
en charge tout de suite et lui donner
ensuite un certain nombre de deux
conseils naturellement
mise en présence de l'avocat au titre de
l'aide juridictionnelle six est victime
le demandent enfin voilà sortir un peu
moi moi je peux pas amener toutes les
associations dans la ruralité
ça c'est le problème de la ruralité mais
on a par exemple songer à ça donc on y
on y travaille pour que naturellement la
victime en zone rurale est au fond les
mêmes les mêmes droits et la même
possibilité d'accéder à la justice que
c'est de ça dont il est question que les
victimes que l'on peut trouver dans le
monde urbain sur les schémas de médecine
légale il ya un travail d expertise qui
est qui est achevée validé et les
besoins ont été remontés par les chefs
de cour et ils ont été pris en compte et
satisfait vous me dites que vous avez
reçu une doléance ou des doléances de
deux magistrats les umj vont ainsi être
renforcées dans le maillage territorial
de médecine légale de proximité et ça va
être amélioré sur le territoire national
évidemment ce sont là des mots et pas
des chiffres pour le court mais je
tiendrai les chiffres à votre
disposition dès qu'on les ordres et vous
dire un peu ce qu'est maillage
territorial on voit très bien ce que ça
veut dire et vous êtes des élus des
territoires mais vous dire
particulièrement chez vous puisque je
comprends ils ont tant que ça vous
préoccupe comment va mettre en place les
renforcer la présence même si s'agissant
également des l'hébergement des auteurs
c'est une de nos préoccupations
c'est qu'il ya des centres de prise en
charge des auteurs ont dit si vous avez
raison que c'est pas victime de quitter
est à la fois son domicile s'il était
agricultrice et son travail
bien sûr donc tout ça nous en avons
pleinement conscience on essaie de le
développer on le développe par des
impulsions qui viennent la chancellerie
mais également par des pratiques qui
sont mises en place localement par les
procureurs et dont on veut diffuser la
la pertinence dans ce site internet qui
est consulté je ne sais pas si on a le
chiffre cseries pourrait vous donner les
chiffres des consultations mais il est
extrêmement impressionnant c'est des
milliers de consultations et ça ne
concerne que évidemment les les agents
du cicr au fond c'est pas consultations
tout public bien sûr pour les raisons
que que vous imaginez alors ensuite vous
me posez même la sénatrice film une
question intéressante mais vous me dites
vous trouvez pas monsieur ménisque
tous ces soucis sont confisqués par la
drass qui devrait revenir au ministère
de la justice
ben oui j'ai envie de vous dire oui mais
il ya un petit bémol qui s'appelle bercy
white mais mais mais alors oui oui parce
que la vasque la drass ne reverse pas
tout ce qu il se saisit à la justice aux
eaux salées oui mais mais mais mais moi
aussi si vous me soutenez sur ce qu'est
exactement si l'initiative
moi je vous soutiendrai mais je suis pas
certain que en termes de finances
publiques
ce soit bien possible en revanche en
urgence en plus ici cependant il ya bien
deux millions prendre cinq qui sont
réinjectés tous les jours j'entends bien
oui oui mais le reste
il semble d'accord savez comment ça
marche le budget wii jouable à vous
aussi monsieur le ministre à faire en
sorte que oui mais c'est déjà pas mal
oui ce qu'on a fait mais comme quoi on
ne fait jamais ça c'est parce que je
suis complètement d'accord bon mais je
vais vous dire je vais vous dire il ya
quand même des choses qui team qui
m'intéresse beaucoup j'ai été amené à me
rendre en italie a peu de temps et les
italiens confisqué depuis plus longtemps
que les français ils sont en avance sur
nous moi je le dis sans ambages la même
façon que les espagnols sont à la pointe
sur les violences qui sont faites aux
femmes en matière de confiscation des
biens mafieux c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'italie est en avance et alors
d'ailleurs à paris paris intra muros y
un immeuble qui appartenait à la mafia
et qui a été donnée au nid dont l'usagé
était donné au nimh savez ce qu'il me
dit bien sûr une association qui se fait
de la prostitution et cet immeuble est
aujourd'hui occupée plupart des mafieux
mais par e prostitué kiki et se
constituer d'ailleurs absolument vrai
[Musique]